this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five
two two five
so john and i were
making fun of obnoxious children's toys
that are too loud and drive their
parents crazy and you ought to buy those
for parents of little kids that you want
to get back at like my kids for instance
and let my grandkids
harass them with loud and obnoxious
games and you had talked about this on
your podcast and that's what brought it
up i think you and i were talking about
on the air the other day that you were
playing hungry hippos which is a
brainless loud
obnoxious game yes it's it's it's a game
of the apocalypse it is it's it's a sign
that the uh the zombies are coming
they're in route
and uh hasbro we were crashing all
hasbro on in the process so thank you
hasbro for bringing headaches to parents
for generations now because hungry
hippos has been around for a couple
generations absolutely
they've been hungry a long time
they just can't be fit yeah and so
we you know just kind of we're just
goofing off like we do sometimes here on
the air when we're supposed to be
answering serious people's serious
questions instead we were screwing
around and uh goofing off and trashing
hunger hippos and you know buy like your
childhood buy your grandkid a drum set
so that your kids
it pays payback for your kids right you
know just in a cowbell yeah oh the other
one was the flute thing right there the
the recorder the recorder james child's
thing he loves god man we just make
fingernails down a chalkboard when they
come through the house with those things
so um
yeah
and they don't i mean uh yeah yeah so
anyway somebody i'm gonna go with hasbro
on this i'm going with a marketing rep
for hasbro just this thing just showed
up it was shipped to me
uh the next day after we mouthed about
it on the air it shows up here at the
office and it's addressed to me
i i'm a little bit afraid to open it
there might be a covet in there or
something
it could be a trap
or maybe a little covet hiding in there
but here's what i love a great bluff
call and so
hasbro well played i'm gonna play this
game at my kitchen table with my kids in
honor of this bluff call i support that
now you already have a you already have
one though right oh we do but our hippos
are huge these are these are these are
baby hips
hippos yeah little the ones we had were
like the size of your hand yeah these
these are like a little wimpy these ones
work out or something yeah these are
exercising hippo well i i still think
i'll give it to one of my grandkids and
send it home with them just to uh just
to spread hate and ascension among my
family tonight man are you going man
today maybe you guys could trash like
the new macbook pros or something and
we'll just see what happens
you know what i really hate teslas i
hate tesla hate them yeah i i hate ford
f-150s the worst truck they're horrible
it's the worst truck ever yeah and let's
see if one just shows up i'm willing
magical i'm willing to give it a shot
you know what i ate yeah ten thousand
square foot houses on a hundred acres
[Laughter]
oh my gosh seriously fun so whoever sent
that uh touche we love you you're
awesome we appreciate it well played um
we got the message
team thanks our our uh what it amounts
to is either hasbro's involved or
someone in our audience has a sick sense
of humor as you and i do which means
that they've been in our audience too
long
no way man hey uh buy hasbro for your
kids just for that move well played all
right that's it yeah oh we're gonna turn
it into an outfit i'm supporting hasbro
i'm team hasbro now okay i was well
played you know i'm just like a nascar
driver get you a little i'm going to get
a
yeah we'll put stickers all over delony
[Laughter]
oh my gosh all right jessica's starting
off this hour in milwaukee hi jessica
how are you
hi i'm good how are you guys better than
we deserve what's up
um i am calling because we are on baby
step two my husband and i
we are really close really close um but
i actually i think we only have one more
i think we are able to pay like by
january and we are debt-free yay good
job i know that part is exciting but i
am actually diagnosable anxiety disorder
adhd ocd just crazy and whenever it
kicks in
i
start spending and
it's it's like
i i almost want to say it's almost like
a shopping addiction type thing
um it seems to hit whenever it's
like my something heavy with my mom
because she recently like passed away
about a year ago
and i don't know if
you guys have any advice about our tips
or anything to help me i just don't want
to ruin this for my husband for my kids
i don't know if you can hear them
giggling in the background but
you know it's so cool to be debt-free
and to be so close but every once in a
while it'll just be
just an overwhelming
you know sadness overwhelming
something and i don't know why but it
just turns into shopping and or spending
money on like the kids or the home or
something that i feel like i can control
and it's just you know any advice would
be helpful
so
number one thanks for being brave and
saying this out loud that's a big deal
right
um i want to reframe the way you think
about this is that cool
yes all right so i want you to never
again think about anxiety or depression
or ocd as something that kicks in
because when something kicks in uh like
when our car goes to turbo overdrive
it just it's gonna take off on us and
then we we are subject to that i want to
flip it around
and suggest this
anxiety that when the ocd gets gets hot
and and welcome to the club i'm i've
been a member of many of the clubs you
just you just uh that you you're a
member of too
yeah they are alarm systems and that's
it
all they're doing is notifying you of
a place in your life where you're out of
control where you can't control what
tomorrow's going to look like where
you're not safe or where you're
disconnected
and
what checks a lot of the couple of those
boxes if not all three of them is you
just lost your mom
right
yeah and that's heavy and when you think
about that the alarm sound
and then
so your shopping is not a response to
the alarms your shopping is a response
to
grief
your shopping is a response to
i need to go do a thing because i'm
trying to avoid sitting and hurt and the
anxiety is that's just that's just an
alarm system okay
so
right
how have you grieved your mom's passing
um i mean
i guess yeah you're right i mean we
just were crying and i just vividly
remember i guess i really didn't face it
head-on because i do remember that there
were other people that seemed to be more
upset more breaking down than i was and
so i just literally remember being told
oh you have to hold it together because
we have to do this for my dad my dad was
having a really hard time so
i don't think you know i'll break down
in private but not you know i'm sorry
that somebody told you that
everybody grieves differently
and yeah when when somebody passes away
you've got the responsibilities of
funerals and things like that but
you've got to honor this this
trauma this is a big deal i want you to
write a letter to your mom tonight
tell her how much you missed her
tell her how much
2022 is gonna be different without her
what you're gonna miss about her and i
want you to start healing there and then
put some roadblocks in front of you give
your debit card away if you've got to in
a hard season i've had to do that give
your debit card away set up some
roadblocks so that you don't spin
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over eight hundred dollars
a year go to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
a lot of people know me as the guy who
messed up and lost everything and
learned my lessons and that's all true
30 years ago
and i set out to learn god's and
grandma's ways of managing money and we
in the process created
this idea of the ramsey baby steps and
by following these baby steps i became a
millionaire
and
by making a ton of money beyond that i
became a lot more than a millionaire but
my first million or two was straight up
following the baby steps like most
people
and especially people listening around
here so we spent the last three decades
teaching millions of millions of people
this plan and so we have tens of
thousands of baby step millionaires out
there if you follow the baby steps you
will become a millionaire
not next week not by the end of the year
because of the baby steps anyway but you
know it's it's a tortoise and a hair
thing and we're tortoise people
we have a new book coming out i do the
first time i've done a book a major
trade pub in
eight years
um and so uh it comes out in january
january the 11th and it's on sale
pre-sale now it's called baby steps
millionaires how ordinary people build
extraordinary wealth and how you can do
it's the exact
process to follow
to become a millionaire and it works
like every stinking time it's not get
rich quick and it's not get rich easy so
don't misunderstand
but this does work and with such
reliability and such statistical
evidence that by the time you finish
reading it you're like
i'm not going to listen to any more
political people with an agenda i can go
do this so i'm going to make you believe
you can do it and then show you exactly
how to do it that's what this book is so
pre-order your copy if you want it's 20
you get 150 worth of extra items with it
if you do that the baby steps
millionaire's audio book and e-book the
legacy journey audio book and e-book
baby steps millionaires live stream
which happens in january
a ramsey smart tax filing to file your
federal income tax free
and uh the ramsey plus 30 day
free trial to go into financial peace
university and start your baby steps so
all of that at
ramseysolutions.com just hit the store
get the whole deal the pre-order special
on baby steps
millionaires brandon is in philadelphia
hey brandon how are you
good how about you better than i deserve
what's up
so i got a few questions here for you um
i'm not sure if you got a background on
it yet i watch your show a lot by the
way
thank you
how can we help so
i'm 21 years old i have about um
i'm having a dilemma with my parents
right now about whether i'm going to get
a job or um
do something in real estate and i have
uh
a few connections that um i could use
and i'm just wondering what
obviously you wouldn't go the
traditional route but i mean i
i just wanted to know
like
what it is i could
i i did two years of college i just got
out and i'm about eight thousand dollars
in debt and uh i have the money to pay
that off
but i'm uh
i've been buying and selling atvs and
that's been working out pretty good i
got about 60 000 saved
but
i just wanted to know if you would
take a risk
continue what i'm doing with the buying
and selling atvs if you would go into
real estate with the market how it is
right now if
you know
i just don't want to get into real
estate look like an idiot to my family
my parents and everything like that and
have them say i was right i mean i
well part of being 21 years old is you
start worrying about what you think of
you 10 years from now not what other
people think of you
they don't get a vote they can choose to
be cheerleaders or choose to be debbie
downers that's their choice
friends relatives we've all got some of
each
and uh but your deal is you got to
square your shoulders and be who you is
dude
um and so you know i i don't really give
a crap what your parents think other
than i want to be respectful of them
okay
but my point is if you know you've got
to decide what you need to do i can give
you some ideas but even what i think or
what john thinks doesn't matter you're
the one that matters
you've got to decide this is what i'm
going to do and guess what a hundred
percent of the things you try probably
won't work one way or another nothing
turns out exactly like you think it's
going to you have this vision of what
doing real estate and being successful
looks like or what failing looks like
and you're probably going to land
somewhere in the middle of those two
things
and uh so it's it's you know
it's it's hard so uh living a life to
avoid i told you so yeah is the the one
surefire way to do absolutely nothing
with your life
nothing yeah yeah
you'll never do anything it's like a
freaking curse yeah the problem is
i just want to know how do i convince my
parents you can't you don't who cares
it's not their job you don't have to
convince them yeah
you got to convince you and you're
you're pawning this off on your parents
for you don't you don't trust you
you don't believe in you
you got it it sounds like you got a good
business going and you don't think it's
in your eyes it doesn't doesn't it's not
a uh a valid thing yeah it doesn't have
a certification it doesn't have a degree
and so it can't be a real job so let me
just tell you if you're 21 years old and
you made sixty thousand dollars buying
and selling atvs you're pretty dead i'm
good at it yes sounds to me like you got
your business
yeah i mean it's just not taxed it's not
on the books that you know what i mean
what is tax income is taxed in america
yeah pay taxes you have to pay your
taxes that's illegal of course it's
taxed
but you need to be running a business
but you've got the ability to do this
business and make money doing it then
you need to set it up as a business and
start paying your debt gum taxes and
making sure you're setting money aside
and write a check out of 60 000 cash on
eight thousand dollars and be debt-free
by the time you get off the phone in
just a minute
uh and then you then what i would do if
i woke up in your shoes
you do what you wanna do 21 years old is
a tough
field to plow
selling real estate because you're
trying to talk people 40 years old into
spending 300 000 bucks and they're
looking at what they think is a kid
so it can be done i did it but it was
hard
and i had to overcome
the fact that i was a baby child selling
real estate at 18 years old i got my
license three weeks after i turned to
18. and i did sell some houses but it
was an uphill
extra hurdles to jump over because of my
youth
and you will have that same thing that's
a bottom line so what i would do if i
were in your shoes is i'd get my real
estate license and start selling real
estate as my side gig and make atvs my
full-time gig until you get the real
estate gig up fast enough and running
hard enough that you feel like you want
to drop the atv gig
yeah i've been doing it through college
so i didn't really take it serious and
you know my parents don't really take it
serious too so i
i do like the money how many times we
got to visit your parents in this
neighborhood don't get a vote
yeah
do you still live in their basement
no i have my room there they're nice
enough to put me up in my own room but
all right
you need to get out 90 days you got to
be going you're going to get out you got
60 000 you're 21 years old grow up go
move got it
when your mama quits washing your
underwear you're now a man my son
get out time to move on this is the
problem is you're still eating at her
table and so she still has she does have
a vote actually yeah yeah so yeah you
need to hit the road jack time
it's not because your parents are bad
people it's called growing up yeah you
know you need to move out it's time
you're making money you're not broke you
don't have a you know go get you an
apartment and go sell buy and sell atvs
or get you a little rental house it's
got a big old garage in the back you can
hold some little bit of inventory in and
and keep your little craigslist thing or
whatever you're doing to move those
those atvs get after it man
you got a legitimate freaking business
going go make you a good living doing it
and let's let's say that the atv
flipping dries up in 18 months
you're 22 and a half yeah you still got
a lot to do
then go back to college and finish your
last two years or then by then you're
selling like this take a
job so much real estate stuff going in
yeah
we're not chiseling anything in stone
here that's right
you've proven yourself
you've proven yourself you have sixty
thousand dollars in the bank if you have
six dollars in the bank in a theory i
might give you different advice they'd
make you a professor
[Music]
tenured yeah
you're just evil
yeah i'm just hey those are my friends
just go to break those are my friends go
to break this is the ramsay shot
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality uh
host of the dr john dolone podcast which
is uh
growing by leaps and bounds one of the
more popular things we're doing on the
ramsey network right now be sure you
tune in if you want to hear more calls
about relationships and boundaries and
mental health issues and so forth triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk okay john i wanna
go back to our first segment we took a
call from a lady who uh mentioned a um
an alphabet soup of maladies uh that she
it was a adhd ocd uh depression
everything else um
and then she was spending when she was
feeling blue yep to medicate
um
and i want to ask you about something
because we didn't have time in that
segment for me to interrupt uh uh and
jump in there but
uh doing financial coaching for 30 years
i have run into a ton
of i mean we've dealt with a lot of
addicts of course because a hundred
percent of addicts if they don't deal
with their addiction become broke right
it's a hundred percent isn't it there's
no
you do not make it out of addiction
unless you're broke or you stop the
addiction one or two okay the second
thing i run into a ton is
legitimately diagnosed
bipolar yep
where they're manic depressive
and they haven't got their meds
straightened out if they're doing meds
and they haven't gotten good counseling
and coaching and so they've accepted
that this is who they are and it's this
dramatic swings
back and forth which affects every area
of their life but we see them as in
financial coaching we see the when they
go manic they spin like manic like a
maniac that's the word manic and so you
spend you spend like you're in congress
uh if you don't get this and uh but when
i've talked to them they are uh
too many times even here on the air
sometimes i would call i'm not a
therapist i'm not a phd like you but i
just have learned enough about that
diagnosis and so forth because i've
dealt with so many of them that they
i think incorrectly
accept that this is the way it is and my
pushback is is that i've also met with
people that were bipolar who did the
work in therapy
and if they're going to do some pharma
if they're going to do some pharmacology
then they've done the work there to get
that balanced or it's not ruling their
life but they they've
made the uh the disorder
manageable towards healing
versus this is just the way it is and
we're always going to have money
problems because i got this so the way
i've framed it
and i i frame this with my students this
way with myself and i look in the mirror
with my friends and family
any of those diagnostics are a context
not an excuse
so they might
adhd
paint a picture for where you're going
to lean in that doesn't it's not a
license to like that's just how i spend
then you need to give away your debit
card right so it may it may impact the
severity by which you have
how far you have to go to control your
behavior
but it's not an excuse just to let
everything roll right so it it it it
provides a context but it's not an
excuse to to be out of control
and
it is
again i'm a lay person that's why i'm
throwing it out here because this is
what i've always believed
because i've seen the evidence on the
other side it is not a
terminal diagnosis
meaning you don't have to die from it
this is curable
to the point that you you can get it to
manageable moving towards healing i'm
not saying they won't always deal with
it maybe at some level but you can
become functional you can yeah healing
is the language i use yeah yeah
absolutely it's not a
um again we're speaking the bell curve
is broad on these things but
most people look at that diagnostic and
they say this is the a path open it
becomes an identity this is the rest of
my life that's right it's an identity
and it's not yeah that's my problem it's
a it's uh it's a challenge we all have
them some are bigger some are smaller
we've got them um i the other day i got
i got a bunch of genetic testing done
from this doctor north carolina's
incredible
um i have something called the cookie
jar gene and it's like
462-911 and here's what he said i think
and you and i may have talked about this
i think my wife's a serial killer
because she can open up a bag of cookies
and have one
and then just put it back
who does that i got a friend that says i
do a line a whole line of oreos yes
exactly yes
and here's what he told me he said at
the genetic level if there's an open bag
you can white knuckle your way through
it not he said your strategy for health
for the rest of your life is stay away
from open bags stay away get them out of
your house don't have them there and so
abstinence that's it don't buy them in
the first place your wife can have one
gummy worm like a somebody who
so you have a genetic sweet tooth
he just said this is good i really like
this doctor he's great he's great but
here's the thing it's a context not
excuse so
i can't have oreos in the house that's
just part of it right when i'm out of
town my white man they go crazy they go
to town because my kids don't have it
either but it's a context not an excuse
yeah you got bipolar you've got ocd
you've got adhd you've got seasons of
anxiety you've got seasons of depression
whatever the thing is
it it's a reality it is what it is it's
a signal that something else in your
life's off and the question is now what
are you going to go do about it you're
going to go get healing you're going to
go see a counselor you're going to see a
doctor what are the things you're going
to go do but it's not permission to sit
you know it's um i was dealing with a
guy one time in a session and he had a
serious anger
thing going on and um
again it's just showing up in the money
the only reason i'm dealing with it i'm
not qualified but i'm like dude
you like to stay pissed off all the time
like every time i'm with you you're
angry
and he goes
well that's just the way it is that's
the way i am and i'm going well just
change just change yeah
bob newhart right stop it five dollars
right so it's like you know just stop he
goes what do you mean i guess he goes
well it's just the way my family is i
said your family is not responsible for
you being a butthole yeah you know
you're just being a butthole yeah and
you need to stop it yeah and he's like
dude who are you i said you come in here
no what's going on this is affecting
your family pattern you cannot
communicate with your wife you can't get
on the same page with your money and you
you get angry and you go do stuff and
and you wear your anger like it's a
badge of freaking honor or something
stop it the great counselor terry reel
says family dysfunction rolls
down
family generations after generation
after generation like a forest fire
until one person stops and turns and
stares it down and says no more yeah and
that's it yep you learned that from your
parents and they learned it from their
parents well great and stop well and
families will name it i had a pastor
friend of mine he said it was out of
sight a phd in psychology as well and he
said uh that you'll name the besetting
sin
and then it becomes a badge of honor
like well we're just passionate people
no you're also temperfed yeah exactly no
yeah it's like we hold our liquor well
you're an alcoholic yeah yeah
congratulations man
we're all just kind of anxious yeah
we're all we're just an anxious family
well stop
be about healing that yes break the
cycle change your family tree change it
and just like you can change your family
tree with debt and you can change your
family tree with wealth these are
behavioral changes this stuff overlaps
it all well how many people we we have
with the debt free stage that say
we just have to keep coming together
once a week and talk about our money
which meant we had to talk about our
priorities and our goals and our future
affected our marriage our marriage is
better yeah it's like ta-da you know
what i mean and how many of them go you
know i lost weight yeah that process not
because we're starving them but because
they said i got i learned this thing
called self
control
how many i can't tell you how many
marriage and family therapy friends i've
got that would love a tool
that a couple would commit to using for
a year or two years or for the rest of
their life it was just a reconnecting
tool it's like a magnet every week or
every budget a budget yeah yeah i've
actually known several that weren't
doing our stuff necessarily but marriage
therapists that they use they forced a
couple to do a budget because it forces
them to talk and communicate on what's
important if you were sitting there you
just got back from thanksgiving and you
are st your teeth are still rattling
from whatever that experience was
you're a crazy family it can be
different yeah if you're exhausted and
you're by yourself it can be different
it it it's your past is your past you
got to own it and then what comes next
someone turns
and breaks the chains like you said
you're quoting the author yeah terry
yeah yeah you turn and they face the
demon in the face and go that's it yep
this obstacle i
this is the you and i did that i'm like
this is the last ramsay
it's going to be in debt and can we be
honest about that for a second you've
got scars
you may die five years before you know
rachel and dan do you right yeah you you
faced it and you got you faced the
forest fire you got burned you got scars
i was in a war they weren't in that's
right and somebody's got to say it stops
with me yeah this is it this is it the
last time you know what everyone
listening here
it can be any of you
any of you you can say i'm done that's
it i've had it that's it i've had it i'm
not living like this healing starts sick
and tired of being sick and tired and it
not only stops with me it stops with me
and everybody after me that's why i'm so
pissed about this i'm done with it
what's up this is how it works get get a
little righteous anger going baby this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today jen is next in
indianapolis hi jen how are you
hi i'm good how are you better than we
deserve what's up
well i am just um well first of all
thank you so much for everything um
we've listened to
your podcast all the time right here
bucks and it's helped us so much so much
tremendously um we actually started
paying off our debt january 2021 we're
actually halfway there
um and yeah um we actually ended up
selling our house as well not just
um
not just to you know pay off our debt it
was more like
being closer to family um especially
with my husband traveling a lot and
stuff a lot of good reasons
yeah yeah exactly um which allowed us to
be halfway there um but i'm actually
currently in a situation where i'm a
little confused on what steps to do
so i actually recently just started a
new job
and i'm trying to decide if this is like
the right fit for me because my daughter
is just constantly getting sick
that means me taking a lot of pto time
because my husband travels
um and everything and
i'm just trying
oh is it
she's just constantly getting like
earaches or like high fevers or like
well actually right now she's homesick
just because she's
if she doesn't get better she can get
pneumonia or something i don't know
but hopefully
she's too
um and she's just constantly getting
sick at daycare
so i guess i'm just trying to decide if
because i really want to keep
pushing because we're so close with this
student debt
we really want to just pay it off just
to build a better life for our daughter
and everything and for us
we just don't know if i should be you
know going to part-time so that way
she's
constantly not getting sick in daycare
and then maybe just prolonging the baby
steps a little bit longer or if i should
just
you know stick in it or stick with it
full time is this like a normal kid
getting normal sick or is she got some
kind of medical deficiency that's making
her vulnerable
um i don't think
well i mean she got some kind of
diagnosis of some kind that makes her
vulnerable to this
well no i don't think i think it's just
like a typical
stuff but
i mean some daycares are just germ
factories i get it okay
yeah yeah are you missing your daughter
oh constantly like all the time
okay so yeah if if
you push back on me tell me i'm wrong
but yeah sometimes
we want something to happen in one in in
one hand and we're gonna find a way to
make that happen in the other
if yeah is there a a part of you that
every time she gets sick which if you
look back over the last six months isn't
it it's not every day it's not all the
time but it is once a month you're
having to figure out something
and that is weighing on your soul
because really at the end of the day you
want to be home with your daughter
yeah is that it and i think that's
exactly like why we are
like really striving for because
obviously we want more kids and stuff
and honestly like we want to have a
beautiful life already kids and
everything but um i think
and that's like the main reason why we
are pushing so hard so that way i could
see him with the kids what does your
husband make
um my heart what i'm sorry
how much money does your husband make a
year
um anywhere from 55 to 60 000.
mileage what are you making at the new
job
um i'm only making 19 an hour um full
time what are you doing
i'm doing administrative work
okay all right at a hospital gotcha okay
and um
how much debt is left
forty four thousand two hundred on what
on student on student
loans it's all student loans
all student loans correct
what's your car worth
nothing which is called we actually
nothing it's pre-owned
well yeah okay i mean there's i've got a
pre-owned car worth a lot but um
that doesn't necessarily mean we're not
i have a pre-owned car worth nothing
same team okay
but okay all right so okay here's here's
what i'm hearing yeah i think you could
work from home
uh
even if it was a uh
some kind of a self-employed idea or uh
distance administrative work for small
businesses and sign up for that kind of
thing we'll all work from home uh start
some kind of small business from home
business boutique with christy wright
yeah uh and make more than you're making
now and be at home with your kid
yeah if you were making 180 000 a year
we'd have to think about this a little
harder but you don't make anything
so you can make almost nothing at home
too
i'm not i'm not putting you down i'm
just saying the good news is the good
news is this is not a lot of money that
we're really having to make a decision
over you're not doing financial
arithmetic damage to your family by not
making 19
yeah you know what i'm saying so
uh yeah and i think you probably
whatever you're getting home with i bet
you can make that if you've got a little
bit creative on what you know again
doing administrative work for small
businesses remote from home
uh sign up for some of those things
and um
you know i i just think you need a new
context because here's the bottom line
uh you're not making enough to go
through the emotional angst of not being
with your daughter which is your number
one desire the sickness didn't get
anything to do with it i would go home
even my baby yeah and jin yeah are you
lonely
yes a little bit and hear it on you
i want you to i want you to get get call
somebody today
and hopefully you got a friend in the
community that you haven't reached out
to in a while you're a working mom of a
two-year-old a traveling husband and
you're exhausted and you're lonely i
want you to call somebody yeah and say
let's get coffee is that fair
yeah okay definitely especially if you
have a friend that is a little bit
entrepreneurial and they'll start
brainstorming some stuff with you that'd
be killing two birds with one stone or a
friend that's got a two-year-old or a
three-year-old or a four-year-old that's
just a few steps down the road from you
now that understands what insanity in a
body that's that tall looks like yes and
a husband that's on the road not helping
the dishes and all that feels like
but i hear it on you that you're getting
you're getting at the end you're getting
an existential exhaustion you've been
burning you've been you've been burning
all the fuel all by yourself oh i i mean
i've i've constantly been working just
so that way we can get to where we're at
now and it feels so
uh blessed for that and every sorry i'm
crying oh you're here's the deal here's
the deal five years from now you're
gonna get there
well you know you're gonna get the other
side of this you're gonna be deep into
the baby steps winning with money
looking back whether you stay in this
job or whether you don't
right so you need to figure some way to
make some money from home so you feel
good about that part of this equation
and you need to go home
yeah can i give you one more
you're a good mom
thank you i appreciate it so much hold
on do you hear what i said
yes you're a good mom
your daughter's lucky to have you
and your work busting your butt so that
her life is different than yours that's
that makes you a good mom yeah the fact
that you're struggling with all this and
having to make tough decisions is all
and all for her benefit also the baby's
benefits exactly right and
and
you didn't call up and go i really want
to go on a european vacation and i'm a
spoiled brat and you know that's not who
you are right now yeah
yeah you got this kiddo you can do it
yeah you can do this yeah but you need
to figure out a way to make some money
from home and go home and you don't have
to do it this week but you need to do it
by the middle of january and if you're
if you've got administrative skills and
you can work the internets right now
especially yeah man you can make some
money doing that hang on i'm gonna have
christy i'm gonna have christy i'm gonna
have laura send you a copy of christy's
book business boutique and start to give
you some ideas and some ways context to
think about that in so very very cool
so there's a lot of different places
that math can take you yeah
um but the number of times i have the
reason i was asking about some of those
things is
uh you know we could i could afford to
be at home if we had um
you know if i could just make about four
hundred dollars more a month well how
much is your car payment 500
exactly let's sell the stupid minivan
yeah well i can't do that yeah you can
yeah you can you're choosing between
your kid being home with your kid and a
minivan that's a dumb choice you get
between you could get between a dog and
your kid right self minivan
but that wasn't her case no she's
incredible this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five dr john deloney ramsey
personality my co-host today as we
answer your questions kevin is in
pennsylvania lynn kister to be exact hi
kevin how are you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
okay so my wife and i are recently
married um we were both homeowners
before getting married and uh put the
coin i won and we're staying in my house
and telling her so we found a buyer for
her house
and we're looking at
taking home around 90 000
and
i just wanted to
get your input on what you thought would
be best to do with that we have about a
hundred and five thousand left on my
house
and it's very tempting to
distill it all of the house seeing how
close it gets us to paying it off
uh but then the other part of me is
wondering i mean i i don't see us living
here longer than a couple of years do
you have any other debt
no no do you have any other savings
we have
so my wife was not following the
babysitter she was very frugal so we do
have
once we kind of fully funded the
emergency fund we had maybe another ten
thousand dollars that we could throw at
it so
i'm sorry you have an emergency fund
plus ten thousand dollars
yes correct how much is in the emergency
fund
twenty thousand dollars okay so you have
thirty thousand dollars plus ninety
thousand dollars
correct one hundred and twenty thousand
dollars in your position and you have a
one hundred and five thousand dollar
mortgage balance
that's correct okay
now part i guess the reason i'm asking
because since we're not thinking about
living here too much longer doesn't
matter there are updates that may be
done doesn't matter you're not you're
not spending the money it's not going
away when you sell the house they'll
give you a check
right yeah so that's that's not a
problem the money's not being lost
we're not we're not throwing it out the
window on the interstate um we're just
uh
paying off your house so okay first
thing is
the two of you need to have uh
more conversations to where
uh we change our pronouns now that we're
married
you're now french we
we we
yeah okay not not her house my house
not her loan my loan
not i won
we have a house that i had before we got
married now it's ours
i understood okay and it's just a matter
of the heart and it's good for your
relationship
and it's good for the communication in
this process so
uh if you're asking mechanically and
tactically what i would do if i woke up
in your shoes is i would pay off your
house as soon as you get the check from
the sale of
the house and formerly known as hers
okay
and i would skip all the way down the
street
yeah you got 15 000 in your emergency
fund you're 100 debt free
awesome how old are you
yeah how old are you yeah uh 36.
what's your household income
um together it is about a hundred and
forty thousand yeah and you have zero
payments in the whole world
you're gonna be a millionaire so fast
it's gonna blow your freaking mind
and that's the goal yeah absolutely
kevin you sound
sad no i'm not happy i'm i'm excited i
the thought of paying off the house is
it just i don't know it's just
kind of mind-blowing it
yeah it is exactly it's i mean it felt
so far away and then all of a sudden
this kind of speeds it up and now it's
like staring me in the face so it's it's
yeah i'm just kind of just kind of
well that's what happens when you marry
well yeah congratulations
and by the way here's how the relational
math works
if she loses and you win you both lose
never say the words i won ever again
just don't even speak those into
existence
congratulations man
that's awesome you got a great start sir
jc's with us in las vegas hi jc what's
up
hi dave hi john how are you guys
great how can we help
um
so i have a very unsteady income um i
have a degree
and i was working in my field for a
little while and i um just decided not
to do that anymore i was teaching
and without with cobit and everything it
was a little too much
for me but
right now my unsteady income like i'm
not making ends meet and i'm trying to
get out of debt
and do the debt snowball and get a
thousand dollars in my emergency fund
and it's it's just a lot it's just
discouraging and i'm trying to find
another job but um but going to job
fairs nobody's hiring me
um i just don't know what to do i feel
stuck
[Music]
why'd you quit teaching
um i
i was teaching out in las vegas in the
schools um i grew up in the midwest so
the school um i'm just like not used to
this demographic and
um
oh
it was just too much and there was like
50 kids under my
like i was in charge of 50 kids by
myself and it was just it was a lot to
handle and i wasn't getting any support
so it wasn't teaching that was bothering
you you got in an unwieldy situation
yeah
yeah yeah so teaching is not the problem
right it's you know poorly managed
school school with bad leadership yeah
yeah
that was the problem so what would be
wrong with going back to teaching then
if you had if you had my teaching life
30 students and
people who behaved
yeah i mean that would be that would be
fine too i mean i tried to go out to um
ohio and teach and i had 30 kids and it
was it was fine and then covet hit and i
was teaching online
and then i was teaching kindergartners
online and it was like it was very
difficult for me yeah but they're back
now um so i thought about
i'm sorry they're back now
yeah yeah
um i thought about like maybe starting
my own piano studio
um that way then i can still teach
um
and it would be a little bit better but
i'm not sure
okay
well i mean you've identified the
problem the problem is you don't make
enough money
and the way you solve the problem uh no
kidding dave is you make more money so
uh that's why we're that's what we're
saying that's what john and i are both
sitting here poking at what's the
shortest distance between where you are
and more money because the first step
with your job is not self-actualization
the first step is not finding your
purpose the first step is eating food
yes
and lights and stuff like that and
that's where you're struggling and so
you know you know and
so if you're going to continue to do
uh the thing you're doing you're going
to do a whole lot more of it or you've
got to change gears get in a different
lane
and um
you know not take the scars of covid and
the scars of a poorly chosen first
teaching gig with 50 kids and just say
that rules out my entire teaching career
based on those two experiences of very
weird situations so i don't know but
what's the shortest distance like what
can you be doing by january one that
pays you four times more than you're
making now a lot of stuff actually
and not random things at a job fair
things that you've already been trained
for
so that's what i would aim at hang on
i'll send you a copy of ken's book
paycheck to purpose
it'll help you move in that direction
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
number one best-selling author of the
book redefining anxiety
is my co-host today christmas countdown
is on
i love christmas ramsey solutions we
love christmas and we celebrate every
year by doing the ramsey cash
christmas cash giveaway
because giving is like fun so we give
away 500 a week we've already started
doing it several weeks already and uh no
purchase necessary you just have to
register you can register up to once a
day so enter every day to increase your
chances of winning and at the end of the
thing up towards christmas we're going
to give away 5 000
ramsey solutions dot com slash
giveaway that's how you sign up and we
know you're planning on doing a lot of
giving and that's why our team has put
everything on sale and we've extended
our biggest cyber monday sale to last
all week long so you can get up to 79
off you'll find special deals from all
our ramsey personalities it's the
perfect time to get christy wright's
2022
gold planner and rachel cruz's money
assessment ken coleman's career
assessment these are really neat things
and this is the best prices we've ever
had on them so cyber monday's running
all this week at ramseysolutions.com
check out the online store our question
of the day comes from blinds.com
they are an incredible american company
and they're the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run all the time you
save even more always use the promo code
ramsey it's like magic you'll get the
best deal all right today's question
comes from allison in west virginia
allison writes my husband and i became
debt free except our house about a year
ago we have four young children and live
frugally on one income
before we met his mother co-signed for
him to get a motorcycle and jeep neither
of which he could afford
the motorcycle has been a sticking point
in our marriage when we were struggling
to just put food on the table i asked
him to sell it he refused and stated
that his mother agreed that it's
important he keep his motorcycle
good
gosh
i'm sorry go ahead this is like a
discovery channel reality show what is
this these people
he recently was my mommy said i can keep
it
as i'm holding my third child
what's wrong with america this you're at
the wussification of america my mom said
my mom said i could keep my motorcycle i
know honey but we're hungry i know
children are skinny i know
he was recently pulled over for drunk
driving oh this gets better i again
asked him to sell the motorcycle to pay
for the expenses associated with the dui
but he refuses
he thinks i'm unnecessarily punishing
him for his mistake
do you think i'm in the wrong for
requesting he sell his motorcycle
wow
no
i breathe
i can tell you how this would go in my
house um i would have got home from work
one day and a motorcycle the motorcycle
would have been long gone
and my wife would have said you owe 3
000 more dollars for your dui because we
got 7 000 for your motorcycle good grief
so i the motorcycle is a token of a
relationship with his first
an original love his mommy
and he's not ready to break up with her
yet
and you are his side thing you are his
girlfriend yeah it's worse than that
though this guy's a spoiled freaking
little boy he's he's i mean he's a child
boy child
i mean he didn't he shouldn't be a
husband or a daddy he's a boy child
and um because he thinks about one thing
himself yeah
this guy's he's this
he's a tool
um
adult
oh my god you poor girl
uh i'm trying to think of can you
imagine saying that to sharon
um hey dave we need you to well my mom
this just would not have even come up i
mean it's just not even on the radar
sharon wouldn't have been around someone
that acted this way to start with she
would have smelled this a long time ago
so here's the thing i i have bad news
for you you have bigger problems than
his mother or his motorcycle you have
him yes
and um
boychild is going to be in marriage
counseling with his wife where he learns
to separate from his mommy
and uh learns to put his family before
his own needs and once and this is
called becoming a man my son
and when boy child does that there's a
chance your marriage will make it
otherwise you are not going to make it
three years
no you gotta you got a guy you actually
have a brain darling dui is with four
little kids he's just yeah and his mommy
and his motorcycle he's reckless this is
just a no this guy's ruthlessly selfish
and uh immature
yeah this is hard dave because i don't
have men like this in my life
you know what i mean like i don't know
these guys well these aren't men true
full players male yeah but that's not a
man i mean that's just a little boy
child
and i don't know if he's 34 or 24 or 64
but he's a boy child
he's emotionally a baby child yeah
and it's just um the wussification of
america and you moms
oh my god
the chances that
my wife would tell my son
to put something she bought him
between him and his child and groceries
you know and groceries
would be like zero none she would have
knocked him sideways no
and that's if i that's if i wasn't
around i hadn't already done it so oh my
god yeah that you know so you moms come
on
you grow you grow wusses by doing this
and we have way too much wuss factor in
this culture
men walking around that are males and
aren't men
and it's not it's not hungry it's not
some kind of toxic masculinity kiss my
butt this is actually caring and putting
other people's needs before yourself it
is a sign of human emotional maturity
correct jeez
male or female but in this case you
little wuss oh my god allison your
marriage is in a lot of trouble you know
that a lot of trouble um this is this is
a mess i'm sorry yeah i'm sorry for you
you deserve better than that you chose
poorly and so now you get to grow him up
or cut him loose and i hope you can grow
him up because i hope he saves your
marriage i don't want those kids to be
without their daddy but uh they already
are so let's see if we can turn their
daddy into something
and uh it can be done i mean i was a
little
twit myself and so i and i grew up so i
can grow up anybody can grow up i guess
oh my god oh
man
no i never i'm not man
we do have a manhood crisis in america
all right hannah is in washington d.c hi
hannah
welcome to the rams hi
hey what's up thank you
thank you so much for everything you
have truly changed our family tree we're
honored i have a question on whole life
insurance policies
basically we inherited two of them from
my husband's parents and i've been
paying them for the last 10 years
and to cash them out
yes
uh well we're just realizing how bad it
is yeah so
it will push us from the 22 tax bracket
to the 24 tax bracket no and we thought
we could cash out part of it no it won't
say no it won't
um this is not taxable well
your basis in these
your basis in this policies are the
total of all the premiums paid the
chances of you even getting out the
money that you put in is very very low
have you already gotten the actual basis
or did you just get threatened that it
was taxable
so we're we have the actual basis
because we had that 177 000 was not
taxable and 63 000 was taxable okay then
we tried to take it out
so it's from 1993 it's 75 55 a year
premium okay so the but the thing is
when we tried to take it out they said
only 78 percent 78 000 sorry we could
take out without incurring taxes and the
rest we would then have to
pay taxes on
uh northwestern oh yeah well i don't
trust northwestern even further than i
can throw them what you need is the
actual basis is the actual basis 178 or
not
so the document they gave us in
september says that the accumulated
value is committed wow not the
accumulated value dart on the basis
how much have you paid in premiums since
the policy was originated that is the
basis the difference in that and the
cash value that you actually receive in
your hands is what's taxable and it's
very seldom anything
and so you may have a little taxes but
you probably won't you need to get with
a tax advisor and even if you go up a
little bit in tax bracket you got to cut
these people loose northwestern is gross
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work first go
to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
ziprecruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com slash ken sign up today
absolutely free and let zip recruiter
work for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage greg is with us hey greg
how are you hey great how are you guys
doing better than we deserve man where
do you live shreveport louisiana cool
welcome to nashville how much debt have
you paid off greg 15 000 in nine months
good for you man and how uh and what was
your range of income during that time um
started out at 30 000 per year
and transitioned into about 60 65. whoa
nice jump what do you do for a living uh
right now i sell cars what'd your income
go up for what happened i went from
being a groundman making like 16 an hour
to selling cars making commission checks
oh okay and cars are selling right now i
hear yes sir cars are made of gold these
days yeah if you have some cars you can
sell them right they're hard to get but
yeah like very cool good for you man
what kind of debt was the 15 000.
student loans and a little bit of credit
card mostly student loans okay what was
your wake-up call 12 months ago and you
start knocking this out in nine months i
had a crazy idea of how i was gonna i
thought it was gonna take like 20 years
to get this debt knocked out i didn't
even know how much i had when i started
at an electric company i met a co-worker
named zach wood and he was just running
around telling everybody about financial
peace you know and just trying to real
passionate about getting everybody's
helping everybody get their finances in
order and that's when they he kind of
laid out the plan and showed me the path
and i said i'm on board all right just
like that huh yeah okay so how did you
plug into us after zach did that
uh you started listening to podcast or
what right listening to the podcast and
uh you know
yes sir okay all right very cool very
cool well congratulations man thank you
how does it feel to be free oh it feels
amazing how old are you 32. you ever
been debt-free as an adult
no sir first time first time wow
it's a different feeling it's a sense of
power isn't it yes sir it feels good and
you're making more money than you ever
made in your life too yes sir that's a
good this is good man life's good it is
it's good praise praise be to jesus amen
have you got that first check
that deposited and you got no bills
i have feels good huh always it feels
amazing you just get to keep all of it
yeah just just save it up for the next
uh career change you know just stacking
it up
[Laughter]
well done congratulations very well done
all right now zach gave you the lowdown
so you can give everybody else the
lowdown because you've actually done it
you it's not a theory you paid off 15
000 in debt in nine months what is the
key to getting out of debt
um it's just making your mind up you
know
being dedicated don't if if you can't
pay for it with cash don't get it and if
you have cash for it and you don't need
it don't get it just tackle that debt
like your life depends on it
total focus
yes sir it's a big deal we ever go back
in debt no sir you sure absolutely all
right way to go man you're a hero you
took control of your life in a whole
bunch of different areas at one time
well done well done that's well played
it's good good good stuff
so uh who were your biggest cheerleaders
while you were doing this stuff um
everybody that went through fpu with me
my financial coach zach wood and then my
mom and brother
okay
so zach's one of our financial coaches
after all yes sir okay and then you went
through financial peace university oh
this is actually that's exactly right
all right okay and he comes along with
you for the ride yes sir cool that's big
time cheerleader makes the trip from
shreveport with you to do that free
screen excellent good stuff so
at a car dealership everybody i mean
that's how people flex right your
co-workers are driving their cars in and
looking good what
people think you're crazy
they do
like you're just like you're not
spending money you're driving your old
car i mean driving the 94 chevrolet um
no air conditioner loving it you know
what i mean that's hot and shreveport
hey you know it is in the summertime
just roll the window down
roll them windows down and just yeah now
you can get the air fixed okay yeah
that's right
at least if not move up in car right
save up and pay cash or make you a move
yeah you'll probably see some deals come
through not right now but it may be by
spring maybe it'll loosen up a little
bit right
good stuff man well done
what was the hardest part for you
uh the hardest part is is the career
change selling cars you know i don't
really enjoy it
i just knew that i could have the
opportunity to make some good money to
get this debt paid off quicker and move
towards the goals
okay
all right so what is it you want to do i
want to be a pilot oh
do some uh
missionary work and uh you know the
ultimate goal is helicopter pilot okay
all right and just kind of see what kind
of doors are opened up you know
well that'll take a few coins it will to
get trained up and be ready to go but
you can do it yes sir very good stuff
congratulations man that's good very fun
fun stuff well very good we got a copy
of the book baby steps millionaires for
you an advanced copy it comes out
actually in january but we're going to
get you an early copy okay thank you the
uh it's called the advanced reader copy
the arc and that's what we send out to
the press as early and so we're going to
get you one and a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away like zach
gave you
the ideas and you'll have it in your
hand you can hand it to somebody and get
them started on their journey like he
did for you awesome very good stuff very
proud of you greg thank y'all well done
man honor to meet you you you took
control of your life and i'm always
honored to meet men and women who bother
to do that it's an honor to be here yeah
good stuff good stuff all right greg
from shreveport louisiana 15 000 paid
off in nine months making 30 to 65.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one i'm debt-free
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how it's done
you know what is so interesting to me
after doing this for 30 years is that
people just decide
they just decide i'm not doing any more
and and they've been going along like
a whole dif whole wrong direction for
decades maybe yeah and then they just
they they get a some new information
and they see a system they can use maybe
and then they just decide and it's like
they completely turn around and go the
other direction i i power of
personal choice is amazing i wonder how
much and i'm just thinking this just now
i wonder how much a picture of
somebody like you
to the people listening to somebody like
zach who kept talking about this
most people never met an adult that's
debt free
they don't get to see that that that
lightness that smile that joy that that
just you know what i mean they get to
see a picture of it and then they got a
plan to follow man and then now let's go
make it happen when you get in the group
with financial peace university you get
community around you the same thing it's
so good but it's uh but you know
obviously that's the money for me but in
anything i'm just amazed i mean i know
people and you do too that they just
woke up and said i'm done i don't smoke
anymore yeah i'm done i used to smoke
would you do the patch no i just decided
i wasn't doing anymore
you know was it hard yeah but i decided
i wouldn't do it anymore you know i was
talking to one of our team members today
he lost 42 pounds wow and i'm like i was
having lunch with him he wasn't that
much of a lunch but um
i'm like what'd you do and he goes i ate
less
i just decided yeah i'm not doing this
and he goes and i you know i it just
decided 42 pounds well you know i just
decided you know and you gotta you gotta
have there's something has to happen
there you get disturbed enough about
where you are disgusting enough about
where you are number one
uh but number two the power of the human
of a human being the dignity of a human
being the power of choice to just
decide i'm gonna change today's day here
that's it and it's gonna be hard it's
gonna be uncomfortable it's gonna be
challenging it's gonna be long but i
still i'm done yeah but i'm done i think
it's an identity shift it's just it's a
switch flip yeah yeah it's like i'm not
that anymore i'm a non-smoker now
starting now what i mean i used to smoke
yeah i am i used to be 42 pounds heavier
yep i used to be 15 000 in debt i'm the
guy who takes care of his body now i'm a
guy who takes care of my finances uh you
know i used to speak poorly with my wife
i never do that anymore that's exactly
no i used to i used to not tell the
truth and now i tell the truth i'm done
yeah you know and you just people just
decide yeah it's just it's so it's so
spiritually and emotionally
psychologically powerful
and it's so draining when you meet
someone who thinks they don't have the
choice
to decide yes you do yeah yes you do you
have
the choice you can just decide
you can't decide to be three feet taller
but um but you can decide to change your
behaviors yeah
behaviors can just you can just decide
you know i i don't act like that anymore
you can just stop i used to act like
that but i'm not like that anymore
i can just decide it's so powerful hard
choices yes
be not conformed to this world but be
transformed
congratulations renewing of your mind
that's how it works
wow
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
scott is in corpus christi texas hi
scott how are you
i'm doing well uh
thank you for taking my phone call sure
my question i'll keep it real quick um
54 years old took me uh 54 years to be
almost an overnight success and
after unwinding a lot of properties my
wife and i are down to
the lessons we have
after we sell it
you pay everything off we'll have about
a hundred thousand dollars
in cash but we have a condo that we're
living in uh that we owe 90 on it
so the loan is 2.6
actually it's two and a quarter percent
so it's it's a it's a pretty good rate
um
you don't have any other debt we do have
a very strong income stream you're
planning on paying it down you know
still aggressively but the question is
do i put the money toward
the loan and just pay it off and come in
there and be like the last guys and
scream them debt free or do they
continue to take that money invested in
other areas and just continue to do what
i'm doing with the house
[Music]
you've been buying real estate a long
time haven't you
yeah uh i have i can i can tell you how
to do it wrong
okay
well um
those of us that love real estate and
have grown up and spent amazing amounts
of time in that world
one of the things they do before you can
start being a real estate investor is
they take you in a side room and they
break your risk meter
you no longer have the ability to
measure risk
um because it just it because people
that buy and sell real estate with debt
are taking amazing amounts of risk and
don't seem to grasp it me included i i
did the same thing as you know i went
broke many years ago doing this
and so and i've just noticed that they
just the risk tolerance in other words
is is astronomical and it causes you to
say it causes you to say things like uh
oh the loan is only 2.7
[Laughter]
yeah like i i hear myself saying and you
laugh yeah
here let me ask you a couple questions
and this will this whole reveal uh it'll
take you where
you know i'm gonna take you um sure the
uh if the condo was paid off and you had
10 or 15 000 in the bank
and you could borrow the money at two
percent
would you go borrow a hundred thousand
against a paid for condo in order to
have a hundred thousand dollars in the
bank
no i wouldn't do that okay same thing i
just did it in reverse i just reversed
engineered it right
i hear what you're saying yeah yeah
exact same decision
so i look at you and i say okay you have
a loan let's say you have an investment
that you can make 10 on then you would
go borrow against your paid for condo
you wouldn't have said no
i got your point
it's the same equation
the difference is when
i make you borrow on your paid for condo
in our discussion hypothetically even
though it didn't actually occur
just the discussion of it
your heart started moving
and you're doing all your analysis in
your head your heart is where you
measure risk your head's where you do
math
i'm so close to being debt-free exactly
i have never in 30 years had someone go
you know i paid off my condo and it was
the dumbest thing i've ever done i'm an
idiot and i went back into debt because
dave ramsey gave me really bad advice i
have never heard that ever one time
oh my gosh yeah pay it off pay it off
and use your great income stream to pile
up some cash and go buy some more paid
for real estate with a piled up cash
scott how long have you been working on
this
oh goodness gracious uh
you know i've had a lot of different
careers a lot of different jobs so i
mean it's hard for me to answer that
question for you it's been a process
to get to where i'm at and it's
you know like anyone else and no one
works any harder than anyone else but
some people get a little luckier and the
decisions that you make and can really
change and shape the direction of your
life yeah here's what that always tells
me that the people that have yourself
people that become highly successful in
any area of their life
wealth building included
do not do it on singular decisions
they do it on an accumulation of small
wise decisions
and you can blow it all up with one bad
decision but you never make it on one
good decision it's an accumulation
a a
a snowball effect of all the tiny little
good decisions you've made over a long
period of time and that's what's brought
you to this positive place you are
you've made a lot of small good
decisions to get to where we even have
this discussion
versus where you were 10 years ago
so you're doing really good all of that
to say you called to ask me what i would
do i would pay off your condo i've never
had a dissatisfied customer on that one
i've had a lot of critics
about theoretical discussions writing
money blogs from their mother's basement
but i've never had someone who actually
paid off their house and was pissed off
right never had never had them pissed
off at me about a lot of different
things over the years but not that one
so all right evan is with us in sterling
virginia hi evan how are you
doing very well phil how are you better
than i deserve what's up
so uh
this camera is coming up here soon wait
a minute you're not talking directly
into your phone we can't hear you try
again
oh no
can you hear me now yes sir yeah okay um
so
looking at a few life changes coming up
soon um
about 10 months ago me and my wife had
our first daughter yay
super awesome super happy
my wife is a teacher
and i'm a photographer together we bring
home about 80 000 ish give or take a
year
um
but with the craziness that has been
going on in the school systems here in
virginia uh my wife has kind of hit her
limit
uh as well as she's really looking to
kind of stay home with our daughter
um and we are currently
fluctuating back and forth between baby
step two and one
um
and i was just wondering she's planning
on uh leaving her job in june so that's
about seven months
ish how much debt do you have left
um we have a combined total of like 26
000.
what does she teach
second grade
reading then
uh basically yeah yeah
so i mean that's one of the key elements
of teaching second grade typically so uh
well
what i was reaching for is this between
now and june i want her to begin to to
build a robust
tutoring
company where she tutors grade schoolers
on reading
okay and she can make more doing that
than she can in the classroom if you
build it crazy money
and she's in complete control of her
environment then
which is what she's complaining about
now right
right and she can do that and still be
around your baby
that's very true yeah she was talking
about trying to figure out
a way if she's at home to possibly make
some money i think she can make more
than she makes now
okay cool but let's start the business
now
okay launch it in january
get it all mapped out start studying
what tutors charge where they get their
customers how are you going to get
people to come and they're going to come
to your house are they going to come
somewhere else and how are you going to
run this business how are you going to
build up front by the way and um
you know and are you going to sell
packages by the hour or how are you
going to do it and how do other tutors
near area price and where do they
advertise and you got to build a
business now and you got seven months to
do it
yes sir and you might have to look at
your photography operation and say what
do i got to do differently now because
we're in this together this is a team
and our global income is going to shift
for a season yeah you're going to gear
up so you may have to take more jobs
different jobs you may have to go get a
uh clock in glock agile who knows but
you got to be honest with yourself about
your photography business and what
tomorrow's gonna look like for your
whole household too right yeah so here's
the thing the point being you're gonna
be out of debt by the time she quits but
you don't even have to take a step back
in income when she quits
okay
household i think you can build it out
hold on i'll have laura send you a copy
of christy wright's business boutique
book
uh equipping women to make money doing
what they love
that's the name of the book
so uh
exactly where you are here
yeah
we've got an exodus of the teachers man
it's pretty been an exodus of people in
a lot of fields service industries a lot
of fields and it has more to do with
politics than it does actually the field
unbelievable and you know we're losing
some of our best
servants in every area of our world
so sad
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends download the
ramsay network app in your favorite app
store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studios it's the ramsey show where debt
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice heidi
is with us to start off this hour in
portland oregon hey heidi welcome to the
ramsey show
hi
hey what's up
i'm enjoying baby step seven yay
way to go
so i my husband and i have a specific
question we have a prepaid legal plan
that we use to do our will and stuff and
we pay monthly payments which irritates
me
and i was wondering if you think it's a
wise thing to keep those around
okay uh is the will done
yeah okay so you don't need to do that
again and we're done having kids we have
four boys and you're but you don't need
to do another will
correct and so you're buying uh legal
insurance against what
uh
that's a good question we thought at the
time it was for our wills and you know
other things that might come up but well
the world's gone
yep
and maybe you have some legal insurance
because you have four boys and they
liable to hurt somebody or something
right
but they're grown gone
no they're home oh they're home okay
yeah
we do have our umbrella policy all the
things that we've tried to follow what
you say and this is that little piece
left i'm like i don't know if it's a
wise thing or not well it's not enough
money that it's going to cause you to go
bankrupt or something like that it's not
enough money is it going to keep you
from becoming a millionaire
i do not recommend prepaid legal or
anything like that i do not recommend uh
extended warranties for exactly the same
reason this is an insurance plan that's
what it is okay and things that you can
ensure self-insure through
you should because 100 of insurance
plans are profitable to the insurance
company
meaning that the probability of you
actually using it more than the premium
is so low that they make a profit on you
in other words if they if the average
person
buying will just use prepaid legal it's
not i'm not mad at the company prepaid
legal but understand if the average
person buying prepaid legal uses the
legal services more than they have paid
in then prepaid legal goes broke do you
understand what i'm saying
yes so we know that they are profitable
on you vastly profitable
and so if you add up okay so what are
you paying like 300 bucks a year
yeah 20 bucks a month yeah 240 240 a
year so uh if you did that for 10 years
it's 2 400
does the average person spend 2 400 on
legal fees in a 10-year period of time
the answer has to be
no
or prepaid legal would be out of
business
well then we had to do something for my
in-laws and we used a different lawyer
because we just felt it fit the
situation better so oh you didn't even
use it
not for this situation it didn't fit we
tried and so i thought yeah
yeah
you're millionaires you're millionaires
if something comes up deal with it yeah
yeah
you need to self-insure through
your legal needs
meaning
i wouldn't pay for legal insurance hey
you didn't use it but here the point has
to be that in your case
on average and you know typically it's
20 to 25 dollars depending on how you're
purchasing prepaid it's somewhere in
that range so 240 to 300 a year times 10
years the average person has to
spend less than that on legal on average
take a thousand people
out of the thousand people the typical
person in there has to be less than
2 400 or prepaid legal is not profitable
when they go to business they can't pay
their secretaries they can't pay their
billing rent they can't pay to keep the
lights on they can't pay their taxes
so they have to make a profit to cover
their overhead and then actually make a
profit which is their reason for being
in business and so we
we just know because that's the way
insurance works
that you uh that you're you know you
self-insure
through
this kind of thing that's why i don't
buy extended warranties on anything and
best buy when you go in there they'll
sell you an extended warranty on a
number two pencil
they're unbelievable and so they make
more best buy does not make a ton on
electronics their margins when you buy a
tv there you get a really good buy
because there's not much margin on it
they make all of their money on 90 days
same as cash that turns into 38 interest
with the finance company and on their
best buy credit card and on the extended
warranties and they're a highly
profitable company on those items but
it's not the the tvs are just a trick to
get you in the game
the dishwashers are just a trick to get
you in the game
and then they make their money on this
stuff and so
it but and
once you understand that then you quit
playing you know you quit going i'm not
buying extended warranties um because
you know they're 87
profit and marketing cost 87
wow the actual statistical use of an
extended warranty is 13 13 cents on the
dollar you can self-insure it wow that's
what it comes out so you know when you
break it down you see how profitable
they are and and why they do it and
you know and again i i'd be much more
uh
angry and passionate about extended
warranties than i would pre-paid legal
but prepaid legal just falls in the same
general bucket because it's insurance
that you should self-insure through
that's what it amounts to lisa is with
us lisa's in springfield illinois hi
lisa welcome to the ramsey show
hello thank you so much it's an honor to
speak with you you too what's up
um
coming up on a year of being divorced
after a 23-year marriage
um
um have
31 i got stuck with 31 000
in
debt um i have thirty one thousand
dollars in savings
do i pay it all off do i not i i'm 62
i'm
not going to be able to retire because
he took a hunk of my
401k
so i'm just kind of i don't know what to
do i quite honestly have been paralyzed
for the last year
with finances i'm sorry
well you're grieving the loss of this
it's real
your heart's broken on top of that my
gentleman friend passed away
unexpectedly on
palm sunday this last year so
yeah so
what do you do for a living now
an event planner a manager of projects
okay what do you make make decent money
um i make a hundred and two thousand
good news okay and how much is left in
the 401k after the chunk was removed
i just checked because i haven't looked
since i had to give him 48 000. um it's
222. okay all right so you're 62 years
old you make a hundred thousand dollars
a year you have four hundred thousand
dollars in mutual fund are in your
retirement plan very good two hundred
dollars
i'm sorry you're in so much better shape
than i thought you were when you first
started talking
your checkbooks your checkbook's in much
better shape than your heart is
okay
and your your broken heart is clouding
your vision on your checkbook
so i would be very comfortable
mathematically and having you write a
check out of savings and becoming
debt-free today and living on a budget
and building up your emergency fund as
quick as you can but i want you to work
on your heart too kiddo
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
i really can't get my head around the
fact that christmas is here in 24 days
wow
and a lot of people are pretty stressed
out right now i mean you got travel you
got bigger grocery bills you got
gifts yet to be purchased
and uh
christmas sneaks up on people like they
move it or something you know i mean it
just
and really i kind of feel the same way
just a second right now the you know
it's
24 days oh my goodness wow it doesn't
have to be that way you can have a plan
for every part of your money including
christmas which gives you a sense of
power gives you a sense of confidence
and we teach you how to do that
in detail in depth in financial peace
university it's the class you should
have been made to take before we let you
out into the world
you know
we're not taught this stuff
financial peace university teaches you
how to get out of debt save money become
wealthy outrageously generous the
average household saves 2 700 and pays
off 5300 in debt just in the first 90
days
and right now fpu is available in a
ramsey plus membership that's how you
get in
you do not have to live with a stressed
out christmas every year
make 2022 the year you finally start
winning
with money
where you're telling your money what to
do instead of wondering where it went
get started right now or you can even
give financial peace universities a gift
just visit ramseysolutions.com
fbu ramseysolutions.com
fpu
lucia is with us in destin florida hi
lucia how are you
hi dave it's such an honor to talk to
you you too what's up
so my husband and i are on baby steps
four five and six uh he's in the in the
military and we own our home uh we plan
to move in about a year and a half
so i'm wondering do we put all of our
extra money billed towards the mortgage
or do we plan for this
move we're currently in florida we plan
to move towards family in pennsylvania
what will the move cost
well um i'm not exactly sure we're
military so they will move us what i'm
really talking i guess i should be more
specific is for our next home when we
buy one or you're gonna sell the one
you've got right exactly yeah you don't
need to save up for the next home you
just pay down the one you got when you
sell it you get the check out of it you
move it up to the next property
okay yeah it's easy that's easy but if
you need some cash to make the move then
you would plan that
okay but that's not make the move is not
purchase a house make the move is pay
the mover and you know set up the
utilities and all the crap you have to
do when you move right
right right okay um so really what i
mean is for our next purchase my my
reaction is to just save as much as
possible so we can put a big down
payment down on our next home you're
going to you're gonna put a bigger down
payment on your home because you're
gonna sell the one you're in
and so that extra money going towards
the house we'll just get that back right
exactly yeah you're not spending it
you're just storing it in your house
you store your store in a savings
account or you can store it in your
house either way you're gonna get it out
when you move
okay okay perfect easy enough yeah thank
you hey thanks for the call thank you
for your service
yeah very cool
dr john dolone ramsey personality my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
richard is in los angeles hi richard
welcome to the show
good afternoon thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
i got a quick question um in regards to
my wife and i uh
rent a town home over here in orange
county and uh we owe about 70 left
remaining on the loan
and
it's roughly worth about 350. we wanted
to pay it off and use that as a extra
income additional income
but at the same time you want to buy our
first home
and
you don't have the money to do both
right uh either i have to say 20 down
yeah so you're really not paying off the
condo in that case or the town home
really what you're doing is you're
borrowing on your future home
in order to have a paid for rental which
you would never do that
no the rentals pay for itself and no you
misunderstood me
yeah i am sir okay let's reach into the
future for a second and let's change the
scenario
completely different scenario you're
with me follow here we go yeah you own a
home that you like and you live in and
it is paid for and you do not own a town
home are you feel sitting there right
now
you feel that okay at that point in
order to own a town home would you
borrow on your personal residence and go
pay cash for
a town home
okay no
is the answer you would not do that
right that would freak you out it should
anyway
and uh in essence that is the net effect
of what you're describing we're gonna
have a paid for town home but then that
leaves us with not much to put down so
we're gonna have a debt on our home so
that we have a paid for townhome and i
wouldn't do that because i would just
sell the town home and pay as much down
as you can on your home get it paid off
as soon as you can and once it's paid
off if you want to buy some rentals
start saving up and paying cash for
those
okay that makes sense
yeah it makes sense that sounds uh
like a great idea okay that's what i
would do yeah just don't don't try to do
too many things at once you're trying to
make this work too hard
uh try to make this one piece of money
work harder than it's capable of working
it's what it amounts to
so there's something that happens
psychologically
with this reverse engineering idea the
sunk cost idea that goes if you hadn't
if you hadn't done it would you go undo
it right kind of thing that what's that
do in the brain i think it's just i
think it's just critical thinking
i think it's just taking a new angle and
a problem and
my
the other day my dog was my son was
trying to teach our new dog to fetch
that's that's the greatest purchase of
my life by the way a new dog what did
you buy not i
off craigslist that's all i need to say
okay um so they were playing teacher
fetch and
i heard him say sit sit about 40 times
and it wasn't working and i went to him
and said hank this isn't working and he
said i'm trying to get her set i said
well try a different thing
and so i modeled what a different way
and it it worked and
then he said oh and i think we get a
picture in our head of the way we gotta
have we gotta retire and let's get
passive income and we got to pay off our
and you just keep banging your head
against this thing and reverse
engineering just gives a different view
of the same picture just from another
angle and you go oh
that's way easier this isn't working i
said sit 40 times and the dog's not
listening to me and just doing it again
isn't going to get get us there right
yeah doing the same thing over and over
again expecting a different result is
the definition of insanity yeah it's
just looking at this at the same thing
i'm just going to do it faster with more
energy that's right i know what's
missing enthusiasm
not him but i mean
we all have a friend in a that goes into
the mexican restaurant that tries to
talk louder slower english
doesn't work genius
good grief doesn't work
it's not a hearing problem no
and it's not a
[ __ ] we all have that friend but it's
so been that guy
[Laughter]
so
yeah i i love that dave as you you take
a problem and you just look at it from a
different angle and you go oh good grief
yeah huh i hadn't thought of that that
happens in our marriages that happens in
our neighborhoods like
i wonder if my wife feels about this you
know what i mean instead of imposing
what i think she's going to think about
this yeah i mean
well i think the uh
the sunk cost idea is where i got it i'm
his harvard investment newsletter and
the guy was saying you know if you
had a pile of money in the table in the
middle of the table would you buy that
stock right now for fifty dollars a
share that by the way you paid eighty
dollars a share for
and you go no i wouldn't buy for fifty
dollars then you should sell it but i
paid 80. now what you pay for it doesn't
matter you wouldn't buy it again you
shouldn't keep it yeah daniel kahneman's
work on some call it's it's it's
phenomenal how we will hang on to
something and just ride it to the bottom
of the ocean
all to try to recoup yes the need to
recoup is is ridiculous so
but you know you just you could do that
with a boat in the driveway you can go
ah boat's worth 20 000 bucks would i if
i had 20 000 and didn't have a boat
would i buy that boat no no then sell it
sell it sell it or yes i would buy that
boat i love that boat then you would
keep it
then you know you just you could say if
you hadn't do it hadn't done it would
you undo it or just you can ask yourself
that about a lot of different things you
can't undo a dog you bought on
craigslist though that's for sure sit
sit sit sit
sit
craigslist dog sit
man
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage eric and andrea are with
us hey guys how are you
doing well how are you good to have you
good to have you where do you guys live
we live up near traverse city michigan
oh yeah we've got a good friend there
man dr mcmeeker is there
very cool good to have you guys how much
debt have you paid off
a hundred and ten thousand nine hundred
all right and how long did this take
four years and one month
all right and uh your range of income
during that four years in one month
uh we're 75 000 to 110. okay cool what
do y'all do for a living
i'm in heavy civil construction my
wife's a stay-at-home mom and as a side
hustle oh what's your side hustle um
well i'm a reseller so i started on ebay
and um i do fight facebook marketplace
cool clothing or um actually children's
books oh good that's good i homeschool
so
that's kind of how that got started yeah
perfect that's a good idea a lot of
people doing reselling in those
situations do very well i hope you do
congratulations you guys thank you so
what kind of debt is the hundred and
eleven thousand you paid off yeah that's
our house yeah
look at the weird people
way to go guys uh yeah thank you very
cool so what's this house worth
uh two maybe yeah two 250-ish possibly
somewhere in there i don't really know
it's kind of crazy that's close enough i
like it very cool good for you guys well
done thank you all right what put you on
this journey and how did you connect up
with us
uh i'd heard of your program when i was
single
and went through the fp university never
really did anything with it and then
i don't know we just decided after we
refinanced our house here four or five
years ago that we're going to start
doing it and pay our house off
yeah when we refinanced our house we
were trying to get rid of the pmi
and we actually used churchill to do
that our credit wasn't great
so um that was that was wonderful we got
our uh interest rate down like three
points wow and got rid of because we
when we bought our house it was in 2008
when everything all the rates were
really high so that made a big
difference
yeah yep okay so a lower rate and got
rid of the pmi and then get after it
yeah yes so it was it just kind of you
looked up and said okay with this lower
rate we got to do something with this we
got to knock it out that was kind of the
first step we knew we'd have some extra
money if we refinanced
we did have a little bit of a hiccup
because when we refinanced we realized
we were in
a flood zone
with the new mortgage company and it was
a different flood zone than we were
paying for before so
we used we had to pay for uh
just we basically surveyed we got an
elevation certificate and then a survey
to get out of it yeah so that cost a
little bit of money so that slowed
things down a little bit but yeah it was
a process and we just worked through it
yeah very cool very good that's such a
great construction answer we use the
process we figured it out yeah that's
incredible that's what all construction
is it's a process and then we'll figure
it out yeah yeah yeah oh very good way
to go guys you don't have a house bank
no don't have a house payment how weird
does that feel i mean how do you feel
very excited very happy about that yeah
how long you all been married
17 years yep you ever been 100 debt free
during that time never wow have you had
that first big paycheck deposit and
you've got no mortgage payment yeah we
actually paid it off in june so
yeah we've
been saving up to come here and
to a listener who can't imagine a world
without a mortgage payment tell them
what it feels like to get a check
i have no payments just look at it well
we're looking at our budget for next
month and we haven't done it quite yet
because we'll be we're on vacation for
another week or so
and i'm like okay we're not saving for
this trip you know we're done saving for
christmas for this year um there's a lot
of money there yeah for this month so we
haven't really decided where that's what
we're going to do with that yet such
problems
i see one of those one of your beautiful
children up there waving saying i know
what you can do with that yeah
well that they do they probably got a
bunch of good ideas yeah i've had some i
bet they're helpful oh yeah what was
what was the hardest conversation yes
you had together like somebody at some
point in this journey said i can't come
on
i need a new fill in the blank or can we
please just what was the hardest
conversation you all had
i i honestly think it was after we paid
off the house trying to decide what to
do next with the money
i wanted to come here sooner
and there were some things that we
needed to to do first money-wise and so
we actually
got into a little bit of fight otherwise
we didn't really fight too much about
the money no
you're the post the first post debt
fighter fight over dave ramsey i've ever
heard i hear a lot of pre-grant but
i was just i think so focused on paying
it off and um i mean both of us were but
i did most of the like i would do the
budget and then he would come in and you
know yeah she was more of the
cheerleader than i was she was more
passionate about it than i was at the
beginning and then took me a little
while to get up to it
it was just a process you had to figure
it out yeah pretty much very cool great
man and i will say when we um refinanced
our house looking at our budget i was
like there's no i want to get this done
in five years we want to get this done
in five years but we did not
have the budget for it at all and so i
knew it wasn't possible but i kept
saying five years five years we can do
this and
we did it four years and yep one month
well your income went up the income went
up and then um because you kept saying
five years yeah probably yeah you got to
have some income to make the five-year
thing work because it wasn't gonna work
otherwise right yeah yeah that's what
you're just you're just looking out
there it's amazing the magnetic pull
what it does i mean it's just once you
decide something and set a goal on it
it's like you know it just changes
everything well way to go you guys he
brought the kiddos bring them up what
are their names and ages um alex is 15.
annie's 13 and edward is 10. ah very
cool very cool now have they
participated in this they know what's
going on or they definitely do the two
older ones have been through the classes
when that there were deals during covid
i scooped those up and they'll be doing
the entrepreneur one soon but oh wow
good they did the online classes and
yeah very cool they did the foundations
in personal finance homeschool yes oh
very good yeah a lot of people scooped
that up during coco
yeah they're very good very good good
good good good well we've got a copy of
the brand new book that comes out in
january we're going to give you an early
release copy for baby steps millionaires
because you're getting ready to be one
thank you if you're not already uh you
get 250 000 paid for house how much is
in retirement
uh around 150 right now okay all right
so you're going to be there in about
three years yeah four years yeah good
good good way to go i love this and
we'll copy of the total money makeover
too to be able to give away and pay it
forward and get someone else moving on
this journey so excellent job you guys
very well done we're proud of you heroes
thank you you paid for house you're
weird people we're weird i love it i
love it i love it all right eric and
andrea
alex annie and edward from traverse city
michigan 111 000 paid off in four years
and one month house and everything
making 75 to 110 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three
two one we're dead free
[Applause]
i love it
wow
ah
i like hearing the kids yell at man
you know i wish we had kept the data
over 20 something years of debt free
screams of what percentage of the people
when they start their debt free journey
their house hold income goes up
because almost every time it's got to be
in the 90 percentile
or something like that almost every time
and theirs goes up 75 to 110. yeah this
is a 32 34 increase this is pretty
incredible
i mean people say household income what
happened is they they said okay we can't
do it we can't do it in five years with
what we make they had a mission they
they didn't even necessarily go i got to
go make more money they just went
the math doesn't work the math doesn't
work the math didn't work and so they
ended up going and making more money so
the math would work and it's just
there's this magnetic thing that happens
when you go
this is i'm gonna
i'm gonna speak this this is what's
gonna happen
it's five years it's five years it's
five years and then boom it happens
yeah when you go looking for opportunity
you'll find it and you look for places
where the world's
you know
you know beating you down you'll find it
and you can you can go like man we're
gonna hit this goal we're gonna hit this
goal and you go look and you look and
you look you find it you find it wow so
proud of you guys
well done heroes great job i love it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today romans 8 37 yet amid
all these things we are more than
conquerors and gain a surpassing victory
through him who loved us
babe ruth said you just can't beat the
person who never gives up this would be
true
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today author of the number one
bestselling book redefining anxiety
one of the many books on sale for ten
dollars at the ramsey
ramseysolutions.com store right now for
our extended
black friday through the whole black
friday week i don't even know how that
works but they're redefining things and
apparently friday is uh self-identifying
as a week now i um might as well there
you go
whatever friday wants to be let's do it
for that friday can be whatever friday
wants to be right
christina is with us in cedar rapids
iowa hi christina how are you
oh good how are you dave thanks for
taking my call sure what's up
um so i have a question for you um
we recently paid off over three hundred
thousand dollars in student loans wow
yeah christina
yeah it took us about four years i'm a
physician
and my question is
i just had my third baby
and
i
feel crazy saying this but i don't want
to return to work
my husband has always been
supportive and working kind of part-time
jobs while
um taking care of the other kids and he
just recently started a full-time job
at a bank and it's kind of a
treat they're
training him
while he's there and it would be a major
pay cut for me to quit my job but um
that's kind of what i'm feeling pulled
to do and i just want to hear your
thoughts on that
wow
what does that what what is he going to
make at the bank when it's all when the
smoke clears on the train and everything
yeah so they're starting at his job as a
credit analysis and he's kind of a
junior credit analysis so his starting
salary right now is 56 000 a year
um and then they told him as soon as
um he's kind of fully trained then um it
would be
in the 60 to 70 000 um would be like
where he'd start at cool and what do you
make now
me um if i go back to work i'm making
about 190 000 a year
okay
all right so we're dropping our income
120 000 bucks to make this move yeah
um if you go from 190 to 70 i mean of
course if you if you go back to work
it'd actually be 260 because it'd be him
making 70 plus your 190 but but you're
out of debt and you're able to make it
on 70 000
um yeah we um
our only debt is our house
and our mortgage what we own it right
now is about 95 we live in a kind of a
smaller rural area 95 000
um
we're in our mid-30s and our retirement
we have about 230 000 in retirement
um are you are you done with being a
doctor
are you done with it or could you do
telemedicine two days a week or go in
one day a week i mean are you just
completely burnt
i feel really burnt and it's really hard
to
give my all to my husband and my
children when i always have that stress
on me um we did talk about i have
reached out to a couple um
like the ceos at a few smaller rural
hospitals about the possibility of maybe
doing one or two days a week for them
in the future maybe when the baby our
baby gets to be a little older
but
what have you got to do to keep your
medical license intact
um i think i'll just have to maintain my
continued medical education and my
license which yeah
my experience with doctors who
have a picture in their head about
well let me let's do separate issues
here one is
um a mom who's like i want to go and be
with my kids that's that's
that's noble great wonderful high
support would never tell you not to do
that absolutely awesome
the other side that the doctors that
i've worked with and known over the
years
are just
quite frankly wired differently than the
rest of us
and the thing that drove them to go to
med school and get through med school
and to get through residency and
rotations
is uh there's just a different drive and
i wonder i i've had several buddies who
end up i'm gonna just go i'm gonna quit
all this i'm gonna go do a small
practice
a couple years later they're back doing
a night a week in the er just to get
their blood pumping again right so i
wonder if you've boxed yourself into an
either or right now and maybe you need a
break but that there's some other
opportunities to split the difference
here
okay yeah i i don't care the money thing
doesn't scare me
what i'm thinking about is
if i were in your shoes
the thing i would struggle with the most
is not i you know yeah i want you to be
with these kids that's what you want to
do let's just let's lay that as the
foundation of the whole discussion um
but you have paid such a price
of uh commitment and diligence to become
a doctor and then as a doctor to pay off
the 300 000 so you literally paid a
price as well
as the as the toll
you have paid to go do nothing with it
for the rest of your life seems extreme
yeah i would agree with that and i think
i think that's what's the hard thing
yeah and i i think you're going to
struggle with that so i i just from uh
you know i i
uh from the standpoint of that i i'm
gonna stay engaged at a
greatly at a 90 reduced level
or or whatever after the child comes and
after you you know take a normal
maternity leave or whatever but like you
said go hit the rule hospital for a day
or two a week something anything uh or
you know
telemedicine like john suggested or
whatever it is you want to do but
something to just keep um
uh to stay a little bit engaged and the
natural result of that is going to be a
hundred thousand dollars a year probably
okay i mean you know that's that's your
that's irrelevant because you're gonna
make plenty of money but but um i i you
know some kind of part-time something
that fits into your new life that you
want to have with these kiddos
but also allows you to
um not just dust
you know shake the dust off your feet
from all of the
the the decade of work you've put into
getting to where you are
i'm i'm sure they exist and they can
write in and let me know i've never met
a doctor who walked away and ended up
staying away because they're that's why
they that i mean it takes such
uh it's such an identity i'm a helper
that's what i do um it's hard to just
walk away from that completely well and
there's just an intellectual and
emotional commitment of time stimulation
uh like the whole thing yeah the whole
thing so anyway yes i would quit uh
doing what you're doing
and so that you can be with your kids
and yes i would try to find some
uh
greatly reduced middle ground
that you can stand on um because i think
you'll be happier uh because your
intellect is gonna require
uh you know you're going from solving
ultra high level problems high level
thinking to can i have a snack can i
have a snack can i have a snack
and uh it's not that one is better than
the other one is more noble than the
other that's not the point the point is
your brain is set up in a certain way
now
and it's it's um yeah
you know uh
a lot of moms of little ones uh while
they want to be full-time moms they also
want to have adult conversations with
adults absolutely and need it and so
that that's that's in the mix here so
yeah that's but yes i would quit
don't quit doing what you're doing i
wouldn't work the hours you're working i
would not stay in the 190 position you
don't have to you can make it on the 70
plus whatever little
plus the other 70 that you bring in or
whatever maybe you can match his i don't
know now let's let's talk about the
person who hasn't who's in that
situation who hasn't put in the
incredible work that christina put in to
get that money paid off you're stuck you
you gotta get yourself out of debt you
gotta get yourself out of that because
you're not in a position to like you
can't lay under a three hundred thousand
dollar blanket yes uh and wait it'll
suffocate you and sleep you won't be
able to sleep that's right and you won't
be able to prosper your family won't be
able to move forward so you you know
you've dug a hole now you gotta get out
right and then you can talk about doing
what she's doing yeah but christina put
in four years of grinding yes they've
been getting they've been helping man
they've been hitting it hard for you
guys
so well done very well done
dr john deloney ramsey personality my
co-host today good show today john thank
you good show ben and uh james stepped
out left ben driving the ship thank god
i left him at the calm
and uh and of course laura filling in
for kelly and so first team's up
first first team's up that's what's
that's what we got here that's what i'm
talking about you never know you never
know that puts us our the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there is ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you